okay imagine your Rainbow six each
player signed to a well-known org that
competes in pro league life is good and
it's business as usual until one day out
of the blue your organization tells you
that at the end of this season the
entire roster is gonna be dropped and
the orga stepping back from CG sports
and so now in the middle of a global
pandemic you're stuck in a team house
for a team you don't play for and you
have no idea whether or not you're gonna
be able to compete in CG sports ever
again that's exactly what happened to
the roster in this story okay before we
get into it if you like investigative
videos like this subscribe to the
channel like the video and leave us a
comment below it helps us understand
what kind of stories we should be
chasing down all right let's get back to
this story so back on Tuesday April 14th
luminosity gaming Rainbow six siege
player hyena dropped a twit longer
explaining that the roster was stuck in
their Vegas team house because of kovat
19 and they were just released from the
org so hyenas from the Bay Area just
outside of San Francisco Vegas is not
his home it's not where his family lives
so you can understand that this is a bit
of a difficult situation for him this
thing exploded on social media and it
was the only thing anyone in the siege
community was talking about so naturally
we did some digging before I get into
why the team was released there's one
important thing you need to understand
pro league as we currently know it ended
on April 13th Ubisoft released a
statement about it and basically siege
eSports is about to go through some big
changes now according to hyenas twit
longer and the interview I did with him
LG released the team because
negotiations with Ubisoft over LG's
involvement in the new version of Pro
League fell through LG made a meeting
with us after like we confronted them
about some rumors nearing they set up a
meeting and they told us that we're
being released due to negotiations
falling through with you and stuff we
said that oh is it true that you guys
had submit an application for the pilot
program he said that no that's not true
we just chose not to send it in because
we don't agree with house running it and
they're not no budging and negotiation
so without and then you know they said
yeah you guys will help you guys at the
transition period and this was all prior
to the like second split of pro-league
best season so we still have like a you
know seven games to play according to
him the players found out they were
being dropped during scrims against
another pro league team just three weeks
before pro league was set to finish what
one of their players had typed in the
chat saying like yellow sorry to hear
what happened guys and we didn't know
what he was talking about and then i
like i he deemed me afterwards and
explained but what he heard from his all
gonna now hyena and the other players
were naturally confused so they went to
Steve Maeda the owner of LG and asked
him if the news was true shortly after
that Maeda and Menashe Kestenbaum who is
the CEO of enthusiast gaming which is
LG's parent company called the roster
and gave them the news now remember all
of this was happening during kovat 19:00
so the team were asking whether or not
they could go home were the airport's
locked down and was LG gonna help them
through this and the answer they got was
to sit tight and wait this changed the
course of our lives to move out here and
do this and for like do Ubisoft and even
LG to some extent to just tell us like
we have no new information just sit
tight and wait and play the rest of the
season not knowing you're gonna have a
spot like in the next season after this
one like it was super stressful super
discouraging you know we all our
motivation was at an all-time low
we're like it completely kept in the
dark and like just the frustration just
kept building and building and building
you know and we were just messaging and
not getting anything and of course if
you're a player it's frustrating having
to wait you want answers now now if
you're LG you're dealing with a ongoing
negotiations with Ubisoft that are
extremely complicated and be a global
health crisis that nobody saw coming now
while all of this is going down with LG
team reciprocity who also had a pro
league team announced that they had to
scale back pretty much all of their
operations due to financial struggles
that's gonna be important soon so
remember that hyena says that he reached
out to multiple people from LG and
Ubisoft most of whom said they couldn't
help him because they also didn't know
what
going on he did stress to me that wine
community manager by the name of Lisa
Marie did her best to help him out she
said she would try to run any questions
that he had up the chain of command at
Ubisoft and hopefully that would do
something but after she did that nothing
changed
hyena got frustrated and because she was
his only consistent point of contact he
gave her an ultimatum Lisa was the only
one that like consistently responded to
us and so I was damning her and I was
like look like we need information like
this is getting ridiculous and I sure
have I just told her like this is
unacceptable like you either tell us to
tell me something or I'm gonna just go
public with all of this shortly after
that hyena says he got a phone call from
the North American director for CG
sports Rob Farini who basically told him
to sit tight they went back and forth
for a while but hyena says he still
didn't get any answers about the future
of LG and what the players should do
about being stuck in Vegas because of
kovat 19 so he decided to go public and
posted the twit longer in the tweet
reads [ __ ] NDA parents didn't raise
me like that 15 minutes later hyena says
he got a call from Kesten Baum who if
you remember is the CEO of enthusiast
gaming which is LG's parent company
according to hyena Kestenbaum basically
said that Ubisoft was pressuring them to
get him to take down the TWiT longer but
also that Kestenbaum didn't really care
as long as he didn't break any NBA's now
as soon as this situation popped off I
reached out to Maeda from LG and Caston
Baum from enthusiast gaming for comment
now Kestenbaum never got back to me but
Maeda did give me a statement which I'll
read to you right now
quote we made every effort to continue
our journey in rainbow 6 unfortunately
that wasn't possible we'll continue to
support our players as they transition
to being free agents by providing
housing in the meantime and assisting
with transportation to get them all home
safely we enjoyed our brief stint in
this game we want to thank you piss off
for having us and especially our players
and the fans for supporting us we wish
the best of luck to those competing next
season and maybe we will be back one day
end quote okay but what happened between
LG and Ubisoft that caused LG to not be
in this new version of
proleague now everything I'm about to
explain was told to me by hyena and he
says he got all of this information from
Maeda from LG and Kestenbaum from
enthusiast gaming so according to hyena
originally LG dropped out of this new
pro league because it didn't make sense
for them financially but then apparently
it looked like reciprocity was gonna
back out of this new pro league because
of financial difficulties which caused
Ubisoft to panic because now they have
to fill reciprocity spot so again
according to what hyena told me
Ubisoft came back to LG and basically
said hey guys I know you didn't want to
participate but now we have to fill a
spot so how can we make this work
apparently to help make this deal go
through
Ubisoft offered LG extra incentives
hoping that would get them back on board
Ubisoft thought okay Rex [ __ ] so they
went to LG and then basically like beg
them to come like I said this is what
Manoj told me and and at first I was
like sceptical you know I didn't know
but what I was told yesterday by some
other players kind of like corroborates
the story it's like I'm fairly certain
this is what happened Ubisoft rush to
meet whatever if demand LC had
originally they weren't gonna budge on
negotiations now they were giving in to
some stuff they were saying okay we'll
give you tier two some other stuff and
then they were gonna get back together
with a meeting and then Breck found an
org which is the org that they signed a
letter of intent with and then they
basically said okay well now LG's out
we've heard a similar story about the
lack of financial viability from young a
player signed to Evil Geniuses our 16th
did you just don't want they want to
keep us and they had plans to keep us
they just again they just didn't want to
move a team to Las Vegas and I don't
blame them I don't think CG is worth
moving of to a [ __ ] LAN league
I really don't now at this point I
haven't been able to confirm Young's
comments with anyone from Evil Geniuses
so let's just recap this quickly
the LG seed roster is living in a team
house in Vegas they're gearing up to
compete in the second half of the split
for season 11 of pro league when they're
told that they're being released by the
org
at the end of the season according to
hyena it turns out the roster was
released because LG and Ubisoft
could not come to an agreement when it
comes to LG's involvement in the new
look Pro League coming down the
according to him at first LG was out and
then once it looked like reciprocity was
going to back out LG was back in because
she was soft needed a team to fill
reciprocity spun and then finally after
reciprocity in another org allegedly
came to an agreement about filling that
spot LG were once again back out and not
competing in this new pro league which
brings us to right now
hyena and the LG team are still stuck in
the vegas team house without a team and
currently without a chance to compete in
siege eSports now the reaction online to
this has been tense people are throwing
shade at both LG and Ubisoft pro players
are weighing in and twit longer after
twit logger has been posted about this
also there's a few different siege
Twitter accounts leaking specific
details about what this new pro league
might look like but as of right now none
of that information has been publicly
confirmed so obviously the situation is
still developing which means we're gonna
keep our eyes on NER succeeds news that
comes our way so we want to scan and
board for this one no why would we
that's not fun I'm [ __ ] loopy right
now alright I don't give a [ __ ]